monsieur le président du congrès
monsieur le président du sénat monsieur
le premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les membres du
gouvernement mesdames et messieurs les
députés mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs en son article 18
la constitution permet au président de
la république de prendre la parole
devant le parlement réuni à cet effet en
congrès il est des heures qui de cette
possibilité font une nécessité les
heures que nous vivons sont de celles-là
le 7 mai dernier les français m'ont
confié un mandat clair le 18 juin
ils en ont amplifié la force en élisant
à l'assemblée nationale une large
majorité parlementaire
je veux aujourd'hui vous parler du
mandat que le peuple nous a donné des
institutions que je veux changer et des
principes d'action que j'entends suivent
ce sont mille chemins différents qui
nous ont conduits ici aujourd'hui vous
et moi
animés par le même désir de servir et
même si ce désir n'a pas le même visage
pas la même forme même s'il n'en porte
pas les mêmes conséquences
nous en connaissons vous et moi la
source
ce simple amour de la patrie